Democrats painting Republicans as
murderers for simply wanting to have
secure borders check out what's
happening in Eagle Pass Texas right now
a massive migrant snaking around in a
line that would make the TSA jealous
thousands waiting to be processed by
border patrol after they crossed into
America illegally Texas governor Greg
Abbott responding to the Insanity by
enacting sweeping new powers allowing
cops to arrest illegals and boot them
back to Mexico so basically he's doing
the job that Joe Biden should be doing
but of course Dems are reacting to that
by playing of course the murder card
when you look at somebody like Greg
Abbott my governor and his solution his
solution is to basically say hey we're
going to kill people that are trying to
come in like that's not a solution the
governor of Texas needs to take a look
in the
mirror of the chaos that he is causing
for this
country this is not just a show Chicago
Dynamic he is attacking our country the
law is incredibly extreme and it does
not make it does not make communities in
Texas safer it just does not it
dehumanizes uh which is what Republicans
tend to do certain Republicans tend to
do is dehumanize immigrants and and and
also uh demonize them and as the Biden
Administration gears up to challenge
Texas Abbott says the White House gave
him no
choice Biden's deliberate inaction has
left to fin for
itself the authors of the United States
Constitution foresaw a situation when
the federal government would be
inattentive to states that faced
challenges at their
borders and in response they inserted
Article 1 Section 10 to the United
States Constitution to empower states to
take action to defend themselves and
that is exactly what Texas is doing you
know uh Jesse Eagle p looks almost as
chaotic as the Philadelphia Eagles
offense last night thanks Craig you
didn't see the game did you no but I you
saw the final score I heard it was
pretty bad it was pretty brutal not as
actually worse than what's going on at
Eagle Pass right now I'd be embarrassed
if I were you well the Eagles should
throw up a drone because they might be
able to see what's going on in the
secondary this drone has changed my mind
usually I'm against technology mhm but
this drone makes you see the people call
it an invasion it's looking more and
more like that as you see these images
in graphic real
terms I think when you say that you're
not going to kill people and you use all
this hyperbole Hitler it's American
people don't buy it anymore the
Democrats have no solutions they just
have smears and we're waking up to that
fact now this guy Johnson is a total
crybaby he's got a couple migrants
coming into a city that has 2.6 million
people in Chicago Eagle Pass has 30,000
people and they just brought 10,000
people into town that's like having a
three-bedroom oh you just went to a
two-bedroom and you still have to pay
for it so the American people are now
wise and they understand that this is a
huge problem and we've been redpilled
have you seen the fox pole you didn't
see the fox pole I'll tell you what the
fox pole said the country overwhelmingly
wants to deport and build walls 2third
want to deport immediately 2/3 want
fines for businesses and we want to send
the military to the border now and Joe
Biden's only at 20% approval for
migration this is like the easiest pivot
of all time so if you say things are
working at the border and it's secure
and then you say the immigration
system's broken and you need the
Republicans to help fix it and then you
attack the one Republican who's fixing
it that doesn't make any sense Texas is
not going to be an asylum Turn Style
it's not going to be a landing pad for
the third world so Joe Biden can turn
Texas blue it's not going to do that and
I and I applaud the governor for
standing up and taking action I'm sure
it's going to be tied up in court
tomorrow yep Danny you know what I
always love about this is while they are
actually demonizing they are accusing
others of demonizing so they're go like
they are de they're murderers it's like
that's demonization talk about
dehumanizing what about all of the women
that have to go through horrible
situations with with the cartels on
their way here how about the fact that
these people are standing out there in
the cold and when kin Jean Pierre says
uh that Republicans want this to happen
and this is dehumanizing and that the
borders actually closed and that is
Trump's fault and everything what's
happening is pictures stick in your mind
her words go in one ear and out the
other so this drone and every media
Outlet could could do this everybody
else could do this I listened to uh NPR
this morning because I'm very fair and
balanced wow I was spitting Nails
because they lead the broadcast with the
the governor Abbott story and about how
horrible this is and how outrageous and
I'm sitting there thinking you this is
the story of a lifetime look at what
what's happening here you have uh what
was it I just saw um
260% over capacity in one tent in one
place in Eagle Pass Plus the other thing
they did is they pulled all the border
patrol Personnel from the highway so if
you were patrolling to let's see maybe
you see something suspicious as a state
patrol office
and you would stop that car and you oh
guess what you found a million fentanyl
pills in there none of that can happen
right now because all of them have to go
there in order to just deal with this
the Biden Administration is forcing
Americans to say we have to do something
different and it might be drastic
they're giving people no choice but to
change their opinion on this they sent
him to Chicago if that that was the
Chicago mayor right yes send him to
Chicago let him take care of it Katie so
he's a murderer because he's suggesting
arresting someone for an arrestable
offense right where does he get off
breaking into a sovereign country and uh
illegally which is also illegal under
federal law they're just not enforcing
it uh to Dana's point about things being
drastic the longer they let this go on
the more drastic the response will have
to be so they are setting themselves up
for that the White House has continue to
try to say that illegal immigration has
always been a problem this is nothing
new this is new this is unpr presidented
what you're seeing we've never seen this
before with the numbers and Joe Biden
claims that he's a dealmaker Republicans
on Capitol Hill want to stop the Flow by
doing some Asylum for reform the White
House is demanding more money to
continue managing the flow and allowing
endless amounts of people in Republicans
are standing their ground in the house
and the Senate and they're saying we
will give you Ukraine funding and
funding for Israel if you just give us
some Asylum reform and some border
security measures the White House has
responded to that by saying as the press
secretary did today that it's
dehumanizing that it's inhumane that
they just hate illegal immigrants um and
the final thing is the press secretary
also was going off about Greg Abbott's
flights or busing to Chicago Chicago is
a proud Sanctuary City the federal
government has been busting and flying
millions of illegal immigrants to
anywhere they want to go for years so
for them to kind of Gaslight and say
well it's inhumane for Texas to do it by
a couple thousand but when we do it it's
Humane and proper and the right way to
handle irregular immigration Harold
great to have you back at the table good
to be back thank you for that the the
the body politic is so divided um and
making it worse is they we can't govern
I don't disagree with anything that's
been said around the table it is amazing
to me at a time in which I'm 53 I
remember what it was like when there was
a national security threat when another
country invaded another country America
was there um you make a a great analogy
about this is federal law that's been
broken also I I I think it's democrats
should stop criticizing uh Governor
Abbott uh you can criticize his politics
and other things but not this issue this
is not one uh I would many of us would
probably be doing the same thing because
if your cities are being overrun with
the thousands that have come there
imagine what he's having to deal with
and the mayor there and local elected
officials there but Democrats and
Republicans you're being given a favor
in the house in the Senate Republicans
are being given a favor because we need
to support is and Ukraine Democrats are
being given a favor because we need to
protect our border so the two of you
come together uh behave like adults and
let's pass something that makes the
nation stronger that en enforces allow
allows us to enforce laws at the border
which means build the wall hire more
agents reform the Asylum process use and
employ every piece of technology as
Jesse said to ensure that we're able to
to locate these big groups of people
coming before they get to our border uh
this is not a Democrat issue in my mind
this is not a republican issue uh this
is an issue that is just broken uh and
it's going to take real leadership on
the part of both parties to fix it and
pressure on Mexico would be helpful
because we can't fly a drone over to see
them unless we have Mexico's permission
so that's a bit unfair hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else